how big of a loss just being a kid from
Memphis was losing Dolph man oh just the
simple fact of just a a person that led
away you know a person that that sparked
inspiration upon me sparked an
inspiration Upon A lot of people from
his hood his City and then he touched a
lot of other all the other 50 other
states you know I'm saying plus the
global field you know of what he did and
what he came about was just his label so
it was a loss and was crazy I tell
people how intuitive and how like
prophetic I'd be top tapped into the man
like the day the day the morning of when
he passed he died before I woke up so I
was still asleep but man I had this
dream of dogs Dolphins I was in the
water with dolphins and they were just
swimming with me and when I when I woke
up I was like what the [ __ ] was that
dream man and like I looked at my phone
and that was the first thing I saw so it
was like that death sparked a wave of
energy across the whole world so you
knew how how powerful he was and what he
built so I always looked up to it